we are asked do the points on the graph
below represent a function so in order
for the points to represent a function
for every input into our function we can
only get one value so if we look here
they've graphed the point looks like
negative 1/3 so that's the point
negative 1/3 so if we if we assume that
this is our x-axis and that that is our
f of X axis and I'm just assuming it's a
function I don't know what it really is
just now this point is telling us that
if you put negative 1 into our function
or that thing that might be a function
or maybe our relation you'll get a 3 so
it's telling us that F of negative 1 is
equal to 3 so so far it could be a
reasonable function you give me negative
1 and I will map it to 3 then they have
at if X is 2 then our value is negative
2 this is the point 2 negative 2 so that
still seems consistent with being a
function if you pass me to I will map
you or I will point you to negative 2
seems fair enough let's see this next
value here this is the point 3 comma 2
right there so once again that says that
look if you give me 3 into my function
into my black box
I will output a 2 pretty reasonable no
reason why these points can't represent
a function so far now what about when we
input 4 into the function let me do this
in a new special let me do this in
magenta so what happens if I input 4
into my function so this is 4 right here
well according to these points there's
two points that that relate to for that
4 can be mapped to I could map it to the
point 4 comma that's 5 up here 4 comma 5
so that says if you give me a 4 I'll
give you a 5 but it also says if you
give me a 4 now I could also give you a
negative 1 because that's the point 4
negative 1 so this is not a function it
cannot be a function if for some input
into the function you could give me 2
different values and you can see that
right here in an easy test is to just
see look for one value I have two points
for this relation so this can
not be a function so this is not a
function I'll put an exclamation mark